La nación del vudú, la cuna de los zombis, la
tierra maldita vigilada por el Barón Samedi,
la loa de la muerte. Según la
tradición, todo esto y más es Haití.
Una tierra caribeña poblada por
demonios capaces de arrebatarle
su voluntad a muchos haitianos.
/ Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
esto al menos es lo que pensaban muchos franceses
cuando esta todavía era su colonia de Santo
Domingo. O también los propios estadounidenses
cuando invadieron el país en el año 1916
De hecho, ¿Sabíais que los zombis se popularizaron
en Estados Unidos justo durante la invasión
estadounidense de principios del siglo XX? Pues
sí, esa ha sido la influencia de este país.
Claro que, seamos honestos. Esta percepción tan
macabra de Haití y de su población servía a un
propósito muy concreto: poder dominar
un territorio que había llegado a ser
la colonia más rica del mundo y que ocupaba una
posición absolutamente estratégica en el Caribe.
Y es que Haití podría haberse llegado a convertir
en uno de los países más ricos de América Latina.
Sin embargo, el destino le tenía preparado otro
camino muy diferente, uno que le llevaría a
convertirse ni más ni menos que en el país más
pobre de América Latina, del hemisferio norte
y uno de los más pobres de todo el planeta.
Más allá del vudú, los zombis y los espíritus,
hoy por hoy Haití es prácticamente lo que
podríamos denominar como un Estado fallido.
Haití lleva en una espiral de inestabilidad
política desde su independencia en 1804. En
estos casi 200 años han sido muy pocos los
gobiernos que se han mantenido estables.
De hecho, seguramente la época más estable del
país fue también la época más cruel. Hablamos
de la dictadura familiar de Francois Duvalier,
alias Papa Doc, y, tras su muerte, la de su hijo
Jean-Claude. Entre ambos estuvieron casi 30 años
en el poder y establecieron uno de los regímenes
de terror más extremos de toda la historia.
Pero eso será tema para otro vídeo. No olvides
Suscribirte a VisualPolitik para no perdértelo.
El caso es que, por supuesto, toda esta
inestabilidad no fue algo fortuito. Tras
su independencia, Haití heredó una enorme
tensión social basada en la raza… Que
hizo que la violencia se convirtiera
en toda una seña de identidad nacional.
Sin embargo, ahora las cosas son incluso peor.
La violencia ha estallado de forma descontrolada
y campa a sus anchas. Grandes partes del país
están en manos de bandas y la hambruna acecha.
Por eso el presidente interino, Ariel Henry,
está buscando una manera de frenar la violencia
de las bandas. Para lograrlo está mirando a dos
de sus vecinos: Estados Unidos y El Salvador.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué ha causado exactamente la
desolación de Haití? ¿Qué ha hecho que el país
esté en manos de bandas y grupos criminales?
¿Cómo espera el gobierno haitiano mitigar la
violencia? ¿Qué capacidad tiene para lograrlo?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(LA ETERNA CASTIGADA DE LA HISTORIA)
No creo que sea una sorpresa para nadie
si digo que entre los países más pobres
del mundo encontramos lugares como
Burundi, Somalia o Sierra Leona.
Pero, ¿qué ocurre si nos centramos exclusivamente
en América? Pues ocurre exactamente esto.
Sí, muchos podríais pensar que Venezuela
y su revolución bolivariana forman el país
más pobre de América… Sin embargo, ya
lo veis, Haití sigue sacando “ventaja”.
Y es que veréis, las cosas empezaron mal desde
muy pronto. Tras su independencia de Francia,
la potencia europea inició un duro bloqueo
contra su excolonia y la exigió el pago de
150 millones francos. Lo que convertido en
dólares y ajustado a la inflación vendría
a suponer más de 700 millones de dólares.
Claro que eso no fue la peor. Ni tampoco la
ocupación meramente extractiva de recursos que
Estados Unidos protagonizó entre 1916 y 1934.
Lo peor fue la propia dinámica de este
país. Las tensiones entre la población
negra y la mulata se intensificaron cada vez
más, las luchas por el poder fueron constantes,
los golpes de Estado se sucedieron uno tras
otro y los asesinatos presidenciales no fueron
algo extraño. Todo, por supuesto,
bañado con un montón de corrupción.
Vamos, que lo que se dice estabilidad…
Ha brillado por su ausencia.
Sin ir más lejos, Jovenel Moise
el presidente que fue asesinado en 2021,
también estaba implicado en casos de corrupción.
Es algo así como la norma predominante.
N1(Miles de personas protestan
contra la corrupción en Haití.
Los manifestantes exigen la dimisión del
Presidente Jovenel Moise por no atajar la
corrupción. Meses de protestas han envuelto al
país más pobre del hemisferio occidental. DW)
Con todo, la característica más llamativa de
Haití a lo largo de sus 200 años de independencia,
y sobre todo en las últimas 6
décadas, ha sido la violencia.
En 1958 el dictador haitiano Francois Duvalier
creó los “Tonton Macoutes”, una milicia cuyo
objetivo era aumentar el control del tirano
sobre el país y reducir el peso y la infl su
ocupación y no que le era particularmente leal.
Es decir, el dictador diseñó una especie de
guardia pretoriana a su servicio personal
para controlar las calles. Y cuando su hijo
Jean-Calude Duvalier fue finalmente derrocado y
se disolvió esta milicia, de repente empezaron a
proliferar todo tipo de bandas, milicias y grupos
paramilitares. Digamos que los miembros de los
“Tonton Macoutes” se buscaron nuevos empleos.
Amigos, la cosa aún fue a peor cuando en 1995
el presidente Jean-Bertrand Aristide
que en 1991 había sido derrocado por el
ejército y que volvió el poder en 1994
gracias a la ayuda de Estados Unidos,
decidió disolver las fuerzas armadas.
Y ¿qué fue lo que pasó a continuación?
Pues como ya hicieron los antiguos miembros de
los “Tonton Macoutes”, muchos soldados también
se buscaron un nuevo empleo en el sector que
mejor conocían. Es decir, se enrolaron en bandas
y grupos guerrilleros o, directamente,
las crearon como buenos emprendedores
Bandas que empezaron a colaborar con las
diferentes facciones políticas. De hecho,
el propio presidente Aristide - el que disolvió
el ejército - tenía sus propias guerrillas,
las “quimeras”, que se encargaban de atacar a
la oposición y acallar a la disidencia. Y así
fue hasta 2004 cuando volvió a ser derrocado, esta
vez por una banda conocida como “Ejército Caníbal”
junto al grupo paramilitar “Frente Revolucionario
para el Avance y el Progreso de Haití”.
Y así, queridos amigos, es como Haití se
convirtió en una especie de partida eterna
de Risk para las bandas, los paramilitares y
los grupos criminales. Ellos imponen su ley.
Y claro, entre las luchas de poder, los
enfrentamientos sociales, la corrupción
y la violencia generalizada, no nos puede
extrañar encontrarnos con noticias como esta:
N2(La ONU alerta de niveles “catastróficos”
de hambre en zonas de Haití. DW)
En un país de apenas 12 millones de personas,
casi 5 están al borde de la hambruna,
y de todas ellas más de la mitad son niños.
A esto, además, hay que sumarle la epidemia
de cólera que está atravesando el país y
que ha dejado ya, al menos, 15.000 casos
y 450 muertos. Que se sepa.
La situación es crítica.
Y ante situaciones críticas llegan
medidas desesperadas. Atentos.
T2(UN PRESIDENTE DESESPERADO)
Ya os lo hemos dicho, la extrema
violencia de Haití no es algo precisamente nuevo.
Sin embargo, lo que todavía no os hemos dicho es
que desde el año 2021 los niveles de violencia
y criminalidad han alcanzado niveles no vistos
desde la dictadura de Duvalier.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué? Pues,
básicamente, por el asesinato de Jovenel Moise
(El presidente Moise se vio implicado en un
escándalo de corrupción relacionado con
la malversación de fondos de Petrocaribe,
el proyecto auspiciado por Venezuela
para vender su petróleo en la región.
Ahora bien, su presidencia no solo estuvo marcada
por la corrupción, también por perpetuarse
en el poder sin convocar elecciones cuando
correspondían y seguir en la presidencia una vez
que su mandato terminó el 7 de febrero de 2021.
Al final, en julio de ese mismo año fue asesinado
por una milicia compuesta principalmente
por colombianos. Claro que el asesinato
a día de hoy sigue siendo todo un misterio:
Dos de los sicarios eran informantes de la
DEA y varios habían sido entrenados por el
ejército estadounidense. Se barajan varias
hipótesis, pero la más sonada apunta a que
ue asesinado justo antes de publicar una
lista de narcotraficantes a perseguir.)
Sea como sea, el hecho es que Moisé
fue derribado, y como siempre ocurre, el
vacío de poder es rápidamente cubierto por
otros actores. Y aquí es donde aparece uno
de los grandes protagonistas de este vídeo:
Ariel Henry, presidente interino, Primer
Ministro y Ministro del interior de Haití.
Y si algo es incuestionable es que desde su toma
de posesión, Henry ha tenido una enorme oposición.
Neurocirujano y ahora presidente interino,
es tremendamente impopular. Gran parte de los
haitianos le ven como un presidente ilegítimo.
Y no solo porque haya sucedido una presidencia
cuyo mandato ya había vencido, sino también
porque se ha negado a celebrar elecciones,
pese a que prometió que para finales de 2022 ya
habría una fecha para los comicios. Sin embargo,
luego argumentó que no se daban
las condiciones necesarias.
Así que lejos de producirse la convocatoria
electoral, vencidos todos los plazos,
nos encontramos con noticias como esta:
N3(Haití se queda sin cargos electos
en una espiral hacia la anarquía.
Los 10 últimos senadores dejan sus cargos,
con las bandas controlando gran parte de
la capital, una crisis de malnutrición y
un brote de cólera. The Guardian)
Es decir, que además de que Henry
se ha negado a abandonar la presidencia, ahora
se suma el hecho de que ya no hay diputados ni
senadores porque sus mandatos han terminado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hasta las bandas
están reclamando elecciones. Pero como Henry ha
decidido hacer oídos sordos… La violencia se ha
disparado aún más. Por ejemplo, en apenas los
4 años que transcurrieron entre 2018 y 2022 el
número de homicidios prácticamente se triplicó
hasta tocar la barrera de los 20 homicidios por
cada cien mil habitantes, lo que lo convierte
en uno de los países más peligrosos del mundo.
Las bandas han salido a la calle para lograr lo
que sus socios no pueden conseguir en las urnas:
el poder sobre gran parte del país y especialmente
sobre buena parte de la capital, Puerto Príncipe.
Nutriéndose del tráfico de narcóticos y de
armas, las bandas, sobre todo las afines
a la coalición de bandas denominada G9, han
conseguido, tal y como podéis ver en el mapa,
hacerse con el control de buena parte de
la costa de la Bahía de Puerto Príncipe,
el punto neurálgico de la economía haitiana.
De hecho, para que os hagáis una idea,
el G9 ha llegado incluso a tomar la principal
terminal petrolífera del país, la terminal Varreux
lo que hizo que Haití se sumiera en un
caos total, ya que el petróleo es la
principal fuente de energía.
Es decir, recapitulemos:
Tenemos un país tomado por las bandas,
con tasas de violencia altísimas,
mucha corrupción, un brote de cólera, el
menor ingreso per cápita de toda América,
ausencia de instituciones y un
presidente que no quiere dejar el poder.
En otras palabras, tenemos todos los
ingredientes posibles para situar al
país al borde del colapso. Y esa es precisamente
en la situación en la que se encuentra Haití.
Y eso ha hecho que el propio presidente
Ariel Henry tomara esta decisión:
N4(El gobierno haitiano solicita
ayuda militar internacional. CNN)
Exacto, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
el propio presidente haitiano ha pedido que
otros países intervengan en el país,
especialmente Estados Unidos. Pero,
la pregunta es, ¿quién demonios estará dispuesto
a llevar a cabo semejante operación? Es decir,
a desplegar tropas para luchar contra las bandas y
el narcotráfico en un país completamente roto. ¿De
verdad creéis que esto es siquiera posible?
Pues, ¿la verdad? No lo parece.
De hecho, Estados Unidos no quiere bajo ningún
concepto tener que volver a enviar tropas, como ya
hizo en 1916 y 1994, sin conseguir prácticamente
nada, excepto situar en el poder a gobiernos
autoritarios que empeoraron aún más las cosas.
Por eso Washington escurrió el bulto y le
pasó la pelota a Canadá. A lo que
rápidamente Trudeau se negó. Dijo
que Canadá no organizaría esa intervención,
salvo que existiera unanimidad entre todos
los actores políticos del país. Algo que como
os podéis imaginar es prácticamente imposible.
Y la pregunta es, ¿entonces qué? ¿Quizás
la ONU? Pues tampoco tiene pinta. De hecho,
hace relativamente poco que la ONU acabó
su Misión de Estabilización en Haití. Y,
aparte de cosechar un fracaso más que obvio,
para colmo la intervención de los cascos azules
estuvo repleta de polémica por haber aparentemente
provocado varias violaciones de mujeres haitianas,
asesinatos encubiertos, la introducción del
cólera en el país, etcétera, etcétera. Vamos,
que es casi seguro que esta vez la
ONU prefiera mantenerse al margen.
Por eso, lo que ha propuesto Naciones Unidas es
que esta intervención la lleve a cabo un país
que creo muchos no esperabais ver en toda esta
historia: estoy hablando de los Estados Unidos
Mexicanos… Sí, ¡México!
¿Y por qué México?
Pues básicamente por la experiencia que este país
tiene en la lucha contra el crimen organizado.
Y no solo eso, también conseguiría aliviar la
llegada de refugiados haitianos a sus costas.
Sea como sea, por el momento está
opción está paralizada. Algo así como,
¡Bastantes problemas tenemos ya nosotros!
Pero entonces… ¿Está Haití abocado a que las
bandas se hagan con todo el control? ¿Terminará
estallando el país? Pues… De momento lo que
sabemos es que al presidente le ha llamado
la atención otra estrategia de seguridad.
Una estrategia que ha copado de noticias
la prensa internacional. Seguro, seguro
que muchos ya os hacéis una idea… Atentos.
T3(¿EL PLAN BUKELE PARA HAITÍ?)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos, hoy tenemos que
volver a hablar del polémico Bukele, para muchos
el artífice de romper cualquier equilibrio sensato
entre seguridad y libertad en El Salvador y para
otros otros el mesías de la paz en Latinoamérica.
Ya os hemos hablado tanto en VisualPolitik como
en NotNews, nuestra newsletter gratuita a la que
os podéis suscribir en notnews.com, sobre lo que
Bukele está haciendo en El Salvador. Pero por
si alguien está perdido, os lo vamos a resumir.
(En líneas generales, el presidente salvadoreño
ha implantado una estrategia de extrema mano
dura contra las pandillas y el crimen
que asolaban el país. Ha militarizado
la seguridad pública y proporcionando mejor
equipamiento tanto a militares como a policías.
Además, para poder llevar a cabo su
drástica estrategia decretó un estado
de excepción que le ha permitido suspender
varios derechos fundamentales como la
inviolabilidad de la correspondencia,
la privacidad de las comunicaciones,
el derecho a la defensa o
la libertad de asociación.
Una medida que también le ha permitido al
gobierno detener a pandilleros y a presuntos
pandilleros sin necesidad de una orden judicial.
Junto a todo ello, ha adoptado también medidas
controvertidas como las penas de cárcel de hasta
15 años por hacer grafitis alusivos a las maras,
la reducción de alimentos y confiscación de
colchones en las cárceles, y la imposición
de sanciones a medios de comunicación
que publiquen mensajes de pandillas.)
En otras palabras, que ha obviado de
manera descarada la protección de los
derechos y libertades individuales. Sin embargo,
a costa de menos libertad y menos garantías… la
medida ha multiplicado la seguridad en el país.
Las cosas como son.
Fijaos.
Como podéis ver, la cifra de homicidios anuales
en El Salvador ha estado cayendo desde 2016,
pero es innegable que Bukele ha logrado cifras
radicalmente más bajas… Aunque eso sí lo ha hecho
a costa de cuestiones tan importantes como la
seguridad jurídica, la presunción de inocencia
y las garantías procesales. Y luego está por
ver qué ocurre con los grandes narcotraficantes.
Pero está claro que todas estas cosas en
lugares como Haití tampoco parece que les
importen demasiado porque tampoco es que existan.
Por eso no puede sorprendernos que la estrategia
de Bukele haya sido considerada un éxito
y ahora el gobierno haitiano se esté
planteando intentar replicarla en el país.
N5(Haití movilizará sus fuerzas armadas
contra las pandillas. TeleSur)
Ahora bien, ¿creéis que Ariel
Henry podría ser capaz de hacer lo
mismo que Bukele en El Salvador?
Desde luego, en el país ya no hay apenas
libertades ni derechos que perder, las bandas
ejercen su violencia constantemente a través de
violaciones, saqueos, asesinatos, secuestros,
extorsiones y demás acciones por el estilo. Por
ese lado no parece que hubiese mucho problema.
Pero, ¿qué ocurre con las capacidades reales de
Haití? Es decir, con su restablecido Ejército,
su policía, y su capacidad penitenciaria.
Pues, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, la verdad
es que con los datos en la mano parece difícil
que el gobierno de Haití pueda marcarse un Bukele.
Como podéis ver, Haití, un país que tiene casi el
doble de población que El Salvador, tiene menos de
la mitad de policías, un ejército de miniaturas
y una capacidad penitenciaria muy escasa.
Especialmente después de la construcción
de la mega cárcel de El Salvador,
que va a poder albergar hasta 40.000 presos más.
Lo curioso de todo esto, por cierto, es que entre
2019 y 2021, Haití recibió cerca de 2.500 millones
de dólares de ayuda internacional que como veis no
ha valido de mucho. Tened presente que Haití es,
según Transparencia Internacional, uno de los 10
países más corruptos de todo el planeta. Así que
por ahí tampoco parece que haya muchas esperanzas.
En otras palabras que el futuro de
Haití no pinta precisamente bien.
Seguro que ahora entendéis mejor por qué
este es el país más pobre de toda América.
La pregunta es: ¿creéis que merecería la
pena que Estados Unidos vuelva a intentar
estabilizar Haití? ¿Cómo puede combatirse la
corrupción en Haití? ¿Logrará Ariel Henry dar
con la clave para acabar con las
bandas? ¿Cuál es la mejor fórmula
para luchar contra la violencia? Y otra
pregunta, ¿qué imagen teníais de Haití?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios y
abramos debate. Como siempre, no olvidéis que
aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas, así que suscribíos a este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si
os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.